the heartthrough right-hander the
28-year-old out of the dominican
republic frankie motas sees 2-1 on the
year of 491 era but
in his last two outings where he has
gone heavy with the fastball he's
allowed one run over the course of 12
plus innings and back-to-back wins
against the astros and the tigers so
here's a rise one not a miss gets him
with a splitter a rise strikes out and
that's the way our ball game begins one
down that'll bring up josh donaldson
josh donaldson's numbers at the coliseum
since he left there and they have been
pretty good ops of over one as donaldson
hammers one to left field and deep
beckett goes deep it goes and gone
donaldson first pitch ready on cue
josh donaldson goes deep and it's one
nothing here's nelson cruz who's batting
at 3 48 pops it up mile high man has had
a high pop left to home plate murphy in
in chapman and matt comes down with the
angle so cruz is popped out and that's
out number two that'll bring up byron
buxton line drive into right field down
the line deep slicing fading and that's
fair one hops off the wall byron to
second base he will put on the brakes
and hang up there that's a two out
double and here's
lifted the left field playable for
cannon about two steps toward the line
he makes the catch kenta maeda's on the
mount today for the twins on the mound
for his fourth start one and one era
just over three and it's his first time
facing oakland athletics arcana leads
off check swing ground ball gets by
maeda it's rolling out to second base
arrives bare hands and throws him out
zarais skillfully making that play if
ariz went to his glove he would not have
had time to throw out cannons good
defense right away from the twins one to
nothing bases empty now loriana so
loriano strikes out swinging chase the
slider off the outside corner and the
batter is loud pulled sharply right side
from sheller wright arrives the second
baseman throws out lowry
and that's a one two three shut down
inning from maida sliding into second
with a double is rooker so the twins
already have their third extra base hit
so here's the catcher ryan jeffers
coming up things hits the ground ball
left side charge it short elvis has it
throws the first for the out and the
ending is over so rooker left at second
and olson's going to lead it off olson
with a grand slam yesterday when you're
getting a look at how miada wants to go
about his business with these lefties
maybe even specifically the big bopper
here ollie nothing hard a lot of soft
stuff trying to stay out of the middle
think about the way might have been
throwing the ball early on here seven
pitch first inning he'll take an
extended at bat a good battle here just
to kind of chip away at him the 2-2
again to match swung on high fly ball
right center field the right fielder
rooker going back he's at the track he's
right to the wall and olson has hit it
out again do your job you stay in the
fight you finally get a submit mixer
over the middle it ties the ball game at
1-1 in the bottom of the second and he
is sizzling hot moreland hit by a pitch
round
single to right center and the asf
runner is at the corners and the number
nine hitter elvis andrus mayeda throws
that's a line drive center field base
hit on the first pitch two to one a's as
moreland scores and the a's have to
leave here is loriano big spot early in
this game a's two twins one base is
loaded two outs
to the back stop and the a's get another
run as seth brown slides it head first
it's three to one rise at second nobody
out here's donaldson now and the 3-0
pitch he swings it's a drive to left on
a line that's a base it arrives to third
base he is coming in to score and the
twins are back to within one the batter
is nelson cruz one for his last ten hole
for six in this series swinging a drive
left field and deep beckett goes deep it
goes and gone twins take the lead on a
3-2 hanger four-three twins in the third
a lead-off double from lauren he's the
tying run as matt olsen stands in and he
skies one to center back is buxton takes
a look up it goes and gone matt olson is
smoking hot and the a's are back in
front they lead it five to four
now seth brown stands in down the right
field line headed for the corner and
their babies gone seth brown unloads on
kenta maeda and it's seven for oakland a
lot of hard hit balls in this series
finale so here's nelson cruz leading off
against montas hit high and deep again
to left center field
and
over the wall and over the reach of
l'oreal nelson cruz hits his second of
the afternoon twins are within two now
the twins have runners at second and
third and still nobody out that gets
away
and buxton will score
and it's seven to six and the tiger run
down 90 feet away here's jake cave and
again the ins pay the infield in and
that gets under the glove of lowry and
polanco will score the tying run and
it's 7-7 man and the twins have runners
at the corners and nobody out nelson
cruz dangerous ground ball the runner
was going it's going to be a
pout at first base arise is going to
score
and the twins lead eight to seven two
down and the batter is going to be
polancos slap to left and a base head
donaldson comes in the two out hit they
were looking for and the twins lead it
nine to seven they are wearing out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's heading home another two out rbi
hit this time from ostedia get in the
score position and give marcan an
opportunity the balls bounce toward
third donaldson tried to tag gets the
ball caught in his glove and everybody's
safe donaldson got it caught in the
webbing couldn't get it out the inside
runners at second and third jed lowry
coming up for the athletics against the
left-hander taylor rogers that one is
driven right center field nobody's going
to get it it's going to bring home a
pair and the a's are down by a run 10-9
minnesota in the sixth here's olson no
blast to left center field buxton with a
diving catch in center oh what a catch
by byron buxton preserving the lead a
tremendous catch by buxton to keep the
twins up 10-9
and matt olson right there lets him know
why me why here why right now alexander
kolomay will try to pick up the save in
a one-run game and there is that runners
at first and third with one out in the
bottom of the ninth and now matt chapman
bans in a 10-9 game this winning streak
is on the line lifted to right field
high in the air down the right field
line ricker going back in the corner
fair or foul and it's foul barely so so
much for the sac fly that was almost a
three run walk off we'll do it again one
and two swings a wide ride to left cave
coming on he's there makes the catch
lariano tags he's going to score and the
ball game is tied sac fly ties the game
at 10 10 in the bottom of the ninth well
byron with an opportunity to leave even
more fingerprints on this game and the
first pitch is swinging to fly ball left
center field and deep back it goes deep
it goes and gone
adding to that day what was good is now
even better
a 10th inning two run blast from buxton
and the twins have a 12-10 lead in the
10th at the coliseum how much more can
he do in one baseball game there's still
more baseball to be played and that
loads him up for mark cannon 40 pitches
by coleman weekly hit on the right side
to his left the rookie bobbles it drops
it no play a run is in so the new second
baseman blankenhorn had a chance to end
the game
and he booted it
it's a 12-11 game oh man
and now base is loaded for ramon loriano
suddenly the winning run is elvis at
second base the tying run kemp at third
ground ball to third gloved by arise
sets his feet throws wide open
and the a's are going to win the game he
throws it away and the a's have won it
two errors in the inning by the twins
and the a's winning streak is at 11.
incredible and the luck and everything
that's going right for the 80s just
continues unbelievable there is a wave
going on and we're all going to jump on
and ride it